there are new developments tonight in
the Florida school shooting with those
joining us now is Fox's Matt fin a Matt
Tucker the Broward County Sheriff's
Office posted a new fact checker website
which it says is meant to clarify
misinformation and allegations
surrounding the parkland Florida
shooting the website says claims that
some deputies were told they could not
enter without a body camera is false
explaining any suggestion that sheriff
Scott Israel or any deputy from the
Broward Sheriff's Office ordered body
cameras to be turned on prior to
entering the school is false however
multiple law enforcement sources tell
Fox News there were some deputies that
could not enter the school without a
body camera that day noteworthy that the
sheriff explains no one was ordered to
turn on their camera before entering it
doesn't say no one was told not to enter
without a camera
the sheriff's new website also says
claims that captain Jan Jordan commanded
deputies to stage or form a perimeter
too soon instead of focusing on
neutralizing the shooter are also false
explaining in part the shooting stopped
when Jordan asked about a perimeter to
protect a nearby school and that the
suspect had already fled the high school
however multiple law enforcement sources
tell Fox News Jordan ordered a perimeter
did not ask for one and the dispatch
logs obtained by Fox News even appeared
to indicate that just 11 minutes after
the shooting began even as new calls of
victims were still coming in Jordan said
over the radio need a perimeter and
after the perimeter command even an
aircrew said it wasn't taking off
because the shooter had not yet been
contained and new tonight the FBI admits
that the staffer who took that phone
call in January in which the FBI was
tipped off about Nicholas Cruz failed to
ask investigative follow-up questions
Tucker mädchen Forest thanks for that
Matt